[Music]
I was wondering whether we could discuss
a bit about your idea that perception is
not like a window but instead it's more
like a 3d desktop does that mean that
there is nothing outside the mind or
does it just mean that we get we
perceive something in an indirect way
right so most of my colleagues in
cognitive neuroscience believe that our
senses were shaped by natural selection
that we evolved and that the selection
pressures are such that those creatures
that saw the world more accurately had a
competitive advantage over those who saw
less accurately and so they were more
likely to pass on their genes that coded
for the accurate perceptions and so the
result is after thousands of generations
we're the offspring of those who saw the
world more accurately and so we can be
pretty confident that when I see tables
and chairs and the Sun and the moon and
so forth that I'm seeing reality as it
is
no one believes we see all of reality of
course we only see the parts that we
need to see but that the parts that we
do see we're seeing truthfully and so
I've looked at that from the point of
view of the mathematics of evolution the
evolutionary game theory and we can
actually run simulations to see what
happens and we can prove theorems and
we've done both and the bottom line is
that the probability if our senses
evolved in we're shaped by natural
selection the probability that we see
reality as it is is zero and that that
means not simply that I know I don't
quite see the shape of a chair correctly
or I don't quite see the colors
correctly it's it's much deeper than
that the problem is that the very
language of space and time and physical
objects is the wrong language to
describe objective reality you could not
frame a true description of the world in
that language it's not possible so it's
not that we get it off a little bit here
or there it's that this whole thing is
just the wrong framework for describing
reality so that seems so
counterintuitive and so out there that I
think
metaphors needed to help understand how
it might be working and the metaphor I
like is the user interface on you know
the desktop interface on your computer
if you're writing an email and the icon
for that email is blue and rectangular
and in the middle of your screen
does that mean that the email itself the
file in your computer is blue
rectangular and in the middle of the
computer well of course not anybody who
thought that misunderstands the point of
the desktop interface it's not there to
show you the truth in this metaphor the
truth be the circuits and the voltages
and magnetic fields all that complexity
most of us don't want to know about that
that's really nasty if you had to toggle
voltages to craft an email your friends
wouldn't hear from you it's just too
hard
so what evolution has done for us is its
evolved us sensory systems touch smell
sight sound hearing all of this all
these sensory interfaces as a user
interface that the purpose is to hide
reality completely to hide really just
like your desktop interface on your
computer is there to hide the circuits
you don't want to know about the
circuits and yet it allows you to
control the circuits right by using
icons and dragging them and clicking and
so forth you can control the reality
without knowing anything at all about it
and that's what evolution did 3
dimensional space is your desktop it's a
three dimensional desktop not just a two
dimensional desktop and the icons are
three dimensional not just flat they're
what we call physical objects so tables
and chairs and spoons and forks these
are icons that evolution is shaped to
tell us about Fitness payoffs and how to
get them so it's all about fitness even
space itself is about Fitness the
distance between me and an apple 10
meters away versus 10 miles away is
telling me that it will cost me fewer
calories to get the Apple 10 meters away
it'll cost me a lot of calories to get
the Apple 10 miles away probably I
should go for the Apple that's 10 meters
away so even space itself is
representing Fitness payoffs and fitness
costs
and so so evolution in short has shaped
us with a user interface that hides
reality on purpose or you know purposes
in quotes the evolution is just a
process but but the effect of the PERT
of the process is really to hide reality
so that so that you're not distracted by
it and you can you you can control
reality without actually knowing what it
is so now the question that you asked is
what is that reality and meet the right
answer is I don't know right if the very
predicates the the language of our
perceptions according to our one of our
best theory is you know evolution by
natural selection if the very language
of our perceptions is the wrong language
to describe reality then it's a tough
problem I what I'm doing as a scientist
as I'm suggesting that well I'm trying
to understand a specific scientific
problem which is for me it's called a
hard problem of consciousness and I'm
trying to think of a theory of reality
that will allow me to solve this hard
problem of consciousness the problem is
this we have a lot of interesting data
that gives us correlations between
certain kinds of brain activity and
certain conscious experiences that we
have so for example we know that if I
take a powerful magnet called a trans
Meg a transcranial magnetic stimulator
and touch it to part of the skull that's
just next to an area called v4 and if I
inhibit my neural activity in that area
immediately
all color will drain from the left part
of my visual world I'll just see shades
of gray I'll still see color in the
right part of the visual world but not
in the left then you turn off the magnet
and color it comes flowing back in so
there's this very interesting
correlation between interference with
neural activity and income the right
hemisphere and loss of certain kind of
conscious experience in the left visual
world we can do that with motion if I
put the stimulator over an area called
v5 I can turn off my ability to
experience motion in the left
filled and it turns out that in in the
science of you know cognitive
neuroscience we've discovered scores
maybe hundreds of these kinds of
correlations so correlations are the raw
data this brain activity is correlated
with that conscious experience and well
of course correlations are not a theory
rooster crows are correlated with
sunrises but that's not a theory for
example does a rooster crow cause a
sunrise well no that's we would tend to
think it might go the other way but but
it's hard to go from correlations to a
genuine theory of what's causing it you
might say well so for example we know
that brain activity that we can measure
with EEG electroencephalograms
we can predict your choices that you'll
make in certain cases your free will
choices seven seconds before you can
tell me what you're going to choose so
here again when brain activity is
cleanly correlated with your experience
7 seconds later of a choice that you're
making so here again we have this
correlation and in this case you might
say well ok here clearly the theory is
the brain activity came first the
experience of feeling like you had a
free will choice came a few seconds
later
so clearly the brain activity had to
cause it and that's too quick another
example a counter example is if you look
at a train station a bunch of people
assemble at the train station a few
minutes later the train appears did the
people coming to the train station cause
the train to appear no they didn't so
even though the correlation is tight
every time a group of people appears a
train appears a few minutes later is not
the case that the people appearing
caused the train to appear there's some
third entity namely a train schedule
that's coordinating broke both so we
have to be very very careful when we
have correlations that's not the same
thing as a theory and then the final
example is
you might say well look when you
actually take that magnet and stimulate
area before or inhibit it you're
intervening and by intervening we can
actually figure out what's causing what
right so you turn off before color goes
away surely that shows that v4 causes
the color experience and that's also too
fast if I'm in a virtual reality game
like Grand Theft Auto and I've got a
steering wheel I can say look I can
intervene I can turn the steering wheel
to the left that will make the car turn
to the left therefore the the steering
wheel is real and it really does have an
effect on a real car no it's not there's
again a hidden reality of diodes and
resistors all the circuits that's
mediating this it only we only have the
fiction of intervening and in a fiction
of causality so the problem we have in
the hard problem of consciousness is
this scientists have gotten dozens maybe
hundreds of these tight correlations we
do not have a theory we cannot explain
why neural activity is correlated with
conscious experiences in particular we
can't offer a single consc experience
like say by conscious experience I mean
something really simple like having a
headache experiencing color
the taste of vanilla the theories that
are proposed are basically only believed
by the graduate students of the
professor who proposes them and and no
theory that's been proposed can even
predict or or specify the conditions for
a single experience like the taste of
vanilla so if you think that neural
activity causes the taste of vanilla
precisely what neural activity is
causing the taste of vanilla and how
does it do it no one has any idea or if
they say that neural activity is
identical to the taste of vanilla then
as a scientist I want to say okay tell
me with mathematical precision what
exactly is the matter the neural
activity that's identical to vanilla and
why is it identical
it's anybody can say anything you know I
can say the moon is identical to two
blue cheese and just stipulate it
presumably you need to give me some
reason why I should believe in the
identity so they can't specify the
identity and and much less say why the
identity should be plausible so that's
the problem we've got it's it's a really
deep open scientific problem and it's
very personal
we all have conscious experiences we
would like to understand what's and we
also we also have brains we'd like to
understand what's happening here what's
why are these correlations there and so
the theory of evolution that I mentioned
that says we don't see reality as it is
has a really strange consequence it
means that when I see a physical object
like an apple effectively I'm creating
that Apple as a data structure in my
interface much like if I'm in a virtual
reality and I have a headset on and
every time I turn over here I will see
something I'm rendering that in real
time I see an apple as I go over here
I'm no longer rendering I you know the
Apple is gone but as soon as I turn over
there yet I will again create a
three-dimensional Apple so I'm saying
this doesn't just happen in virtual
reality it happens in everyday life I
look over here I see an apple
I'm literally creating that data
structure because now I'm effectively an
Apple as a description of fitness
payoffs and how to get them it's all
about fitness that's the key thing
evolution is all about fitness but that
means that the objects don't exist as
pre-existing things when I see an apple
we like to think well I'm that's because
there really is an apple and I'm saying
no no there's some other reality out
there but just like the blue icon on
your desktop doesn't resemble the true
file the Apple does not resemble
anything in objective reality it's an
abstract data structure that's just
telling you how to act to get fitness
payoffs here's the kicker when you look
inside your brain inside your skull and
you see a brain that's also just a data
structure that you're creating neurons
are just data structures they don't
exist and this is the weird stuff I
don't have a brain
when no one looks and some of my
colleagues would say yeah I agree with
that you don't have a brain but but they
have the point of this is that that we
create any physical object that we see
in the moment that we see it and so
neurons don't exist when they're not
perceived therefore neurons could not be
the source of our conscious experiences
in fact space-time itself is just your
data structure so the idea that
space-time exists and has existed for 14
billion years as a pre-existing stage on
which the drama of life plays out is
also deeply wrong space-time itself is
just a data structure that would create
so what is reality it's long answer to
your question but the answer is I don't
know but I'm trying to come up with a
reality that would allow me to solve
this hard problem of consciousness so if
the brain is just a symbol that we
create when we look you know trying to
understand how consciousness is related
to it if I start with during which
consciousness is fundamental and I have
to do it scientifically say what do I
mean precisely by a consciousness with
mathematical precision and and I have
this theory of that called conscious
agents in which conscious agents
interact it's like a the proposal is
that reality is a vast social network
it's a heat like a Twitter verse or
Facebook so it's a big social network of
conscious agents that's the reality
they're not in space and time there
they're just consciousness is
interacting with each other as they
interact they are passing experiences
back and forth and there's it's an
infinite Twitterverse yeah an infinite
set of consciousness is out there in
this in this big social universe social
you know yeah social networking
universally and any single conscious
agent in that network would be
overwhelmed trying to understand all of
it like if you're trying to understand
Twitter there's tens of millions
hundreds of millions of users billions
of tweets how are you going to try to
understand what's going on in the
Twitterverse well you can't but what you
can do is you can use visualization
tools suppose I have a visualization
tool that compresses that all down shows
you what's trending in this city and
what's trending over there so you
compress it all down and maybe into
something that you can
through a headset so that you can
actually look here's the Twitterverse
and in London here's the Twitterverse
and Edinboro and so forth and here's
what's what's going on here's what's
trending then you could sort of
visualize it that's what evolution did
for us the reality is this big vast
social network of interacting conscious
agents each individual agent would be
overwhelmed because it's infinite social
network and so what we call the physical
world just is our visualization tool
that's what we have so we've mistaken so
this is all a big visualization tool
space-time and physical objects are the
way we visualize our interaction with
this vast universe of social networking
at university I'll give you one concrete
example to really bring it home when you
look at your face in the mirror all you
see literally is skin hair and eyes but
what you know firsthand that you don't
see in the mirror is the whole universe
of your conscious experiences your hopes
your desires your aspirations your
headache the the sound of music that
you're hearing right now your love of
music all the stuff that's you that's
it's almost infinitely complicated
universe of conscious experiences all we
can see is this and compared to the vast
universe of our conscious experience
this is extremely simple
if I smile you can guess that I'm happy
I'm filling some conscious experience
but a smile does not resemble happiness
it's just it signifies it and so think
about it this way your face my face the
the face that you're creating when you
look at me is your portal into my
conscious experiences the face that I
see when I look at you is my portal into
your conscious experience it's a portal
but it's very very small portal most of
you is left out you can't see it in the
mirror I can't see it from outside when
I look at my cat the portal is even
worse I mean I can figure out maybe the
cat likes this kind of food and doesn't
like that likes it when I pet but now
I've petted it too much now I need a
stop when I look at an ant
my interface is really giving up I have
no insight into the conscious agents in
this vast network that I'm interacting
with and when I get to what I call a
rock my interface has given up but it
has to give up I have a finite interface
I'm dealing with an infinite social
network of course the interface that's
its purpose as to throw most of the
information away to simplify things and
allow me to negotiate with this universe
of you know interacting conscious agents
without getting overwhelmed and so of
course at some point it's not gonna look
conscious anymore at all my interface is
giving up what we've done is we've
mistaken a necessary limitation of our
interface as a and we've taken it to be
an insight into the fundamental
fundamental nature of reality we've
assumed it reality fundamentally is
unconscious because at the simplest
level our interface is necessarily
unconscious so physicalism is a very
simple mistake this assumption that
space time and matter are fundamental is
a simple mistake we've mistaken a limit
of our interface as an insight into
objective reality but it's it we can we
can break out of it it's it's the
natural mistake we could break out of it
okay so where do you stand in relation
to pants.i chasm then if we if we ended
on physicalism that's the obvious kind
of opposite theory to physical is so so
pants I could pad psychism is an
interesting theory there are a couple of
versions of it and when I talk to
different pants I kists they they will
say no that's not my version so I'll
talk about two different versions of it
that so in one version is more dualist
so an electron really exists and it
really does have physical properties
whether or not it's observed like
position momentum and spin but in
addition it has a unit of consciousness
and when electron and a proton get
together then somehow the unit of
consciousness from the electron and the
unit of consciousness from the proton
have to interact to create the
consciousness of you know of the to put
they're coming together right into
hydrogen say
so that's that's one theory it's dualist
and most scientists don't like dualism
right so so most scientists would just
not even go there if it may you know
it's not that it's wrong it's just that
we try to come up with a simplest theory
so another version of pants psychism
that some people talk about it in some
sense is what you would just say well
what I was already saying that the
fundamental nature of reality just is
consciousness and some pants I kiss that
I've talked with will will say when I
talk about all these conscious agents
the word agent makes it sound like
there's all these selves and
personalities and so forth and and I'm
not trying to imply that I'm just saying
that there are these elementary
perceivers that can have experiences and
take simple actions in the mathematical
model I don't assume that there's a self
I don't assume intelligence problem
solving creativity in memory even but
what I can show mathematically is I can
from the network with these simple
conscious agents I can build networks
that simulate selves that simulate
intelligence that have memories and so
forth so so that that version if that's
what people mean by pen psychism then
then it's equivalent to what I'm saying
but I like to just call my theory
conscious realism because I want to be
very very clear that I'm saying that
consciousness is fundamental and I'm
proposing I mean I don't know what the
truth is I'm just a scientist I'm just
proposing a bold hypothesis that
constant ISM consciousness is
fundamental and it's real now if that's
false it's false we'll find out but the
idea of science is to be precise and
bold so that we can precisely find out
where we're wrong so I'm making a
precise and bull hypothesis and it's
mathematically precise I published it so
any scientist can go out there and say
this is what's wrong with the
mathematics but that's the whole goal of
course I'm probably wrong I don't think
any scientific theory I've read so far
is correct including general relativity
and quantum field theory and so forth
they're brilliant they're wonderful
tools we should study them they're the
best we've got so far and they're almost
surely deeply wrong
and so the same is true of my theory I
won't say it's brilliant ball say it's
probably deeply wrong at least as
precise what does it mean that
consciousness is real as real as well
that's that's a great question and this
brings up a really important aspect
about scientific theories and it's a
aspect of scientific theories it really
bothers me in science we cannot explain
everything we always in our theories we
have to say please grant me these two or
three assumptions we want them as few as
possible but those assumptions are just
given the theory does not explain them
they're like miracles with respect to
the theory and in the scientist and says
if you will grab me these assumptions
then I can build this really powerful
theory so for example grant me
space-time and quantum fields if you'll
grant me that then I can then show you
how you know chemistry and biology and
psychology and you know so forth might
arise from that and so the the point in
any scientific theory is you have to say
I'm proposing these things are
fundamental in the universe how did they
get there I don't know I really don't
know just please grant me that in it in
that sense they're real with respect to
the theory these are the fundamental
assumptions about quote-unquote reality
that the scientific theory is making so
it's in that sense I'm saying for sake
of argument please grant me that
conscious experience is like the taste
of vanilla having a headache that these
are the fundamental furniture of the
universe not space-time and atoms and
quarks and so forth the these raw
experiences as as experiences are the
fundamental aspect of reality so for my
theory those are the miracles those are
the miracles and then if you grant me
that then I will show how we can create
space-time and physical objects as a
user interface to this whole vast social
network of these conscious experiencers
that are having these experiences where
the experiences themselves are taken for
granted but the dynamics about the
experiences now is where we can do our
science where we can actually have
an explanation how did you get to these
ideas and did you ever believe in the
mainstream ideas about reality and
consciousness
I absolutely believe the mainstream
ideas and I still remember it was 1986
when I was working on a mathematical
model of perception with a couple of
colleagues Bruce Bennett and shaitaan
Prakash and we'd work out a mathematical
model of I wasn't really working on the
consciousness thing per se I was working
on just how can we get a general theory
about what it means to when we're
perceiving and it was looking at the
mathematics that I suddenly realized
that it was suggesting to me that we
might not necessarily have to see
reality as it is and that was so
stunning I had to sit down but it took
me another 20 years before I decided to
actually pursue that using evolutionary
game theory I began to say okay is it
really true if if our senses evolved and
we're shaped by natural selection can I
settle this issue would natural
selection actually favor perceptions
that show us the truth not all the truth
but some of the truth or will natural
selection actually drive truth to
complete extinction and then it was
stunning to me I was surprised how the
math came out when it actually said for
very deep principle reasons that natural
selection would drive any true
perceptions to complete extinction so so
it's been it's not just been an
intellectual Odyssey it's been an
emotional Odyssey this is upsetting it's
actually upsetting to realize that
something I deeply believed all my life
is just fundamentally wrong and so I can
understand why people might hear this
and go that this is just too crazy does
it change the way you experience day
experience life on a day-to-day basis
very very slowly it's been slowly
changing I think and there may be a good
reason evolutionarily I mean evolution
there's no selection pressures for us to
know that we don't see the truth right
if you're if you have a user interface
and it's working to keep you alive long
enough to reproduce it's doing what it
needs to do there's no selection
pressures to also tell you oh by the way
this is just a game you're not you're
not seeing the truth this is just a user
interface and and so we deeply believe
it we in fact we believe that because we
have to take our perceptions seriously
right if we read that we should
therefore also take them literally I
mean one objection people give to me is
to say you know Don if you're if you
think that that train coming down the
tracks at 200 miles an hour is just an
icon in your interface why don't you
just hop in front of it and after you're
dead and this silly theory with you will
know that that train was real it's not
just an icon and it really can kill and
and I wouldn't jump in front of the
train for the same reason I wouldn't
drag my blue icon to the trashcan icon
carelessly not because I take the icon
literally the the file is not blue and
rectangular but I do take the icon
seriously if I drag it to the trashcan
I could lose my work maybe I've written
a book and has taken me a couple of
years I could lose all that work so I
better take the icon seriously but that
does not entitle me to take it literally
and so that's part of human nature we
were inclined to this illogical
assumption that because we have to take
all of our perceptions seriously we're
entitled today to take them literally
the reason we have to take them
seriously is evolution shape them to
keep us alive so if you see a cliff
don't step off if you see a snake don't
grab it unless you know what you're
doing if you see a train don't jump in
front you have to take it seriously but
that does not logically entitle us to
take it literally so as a result it's
not a surprise that even after I've sort
of intellectually began to realize that
that's what evolution is done this is
just an interface is not the truth when
I'm not you know putting on my rational
head and thinking about it I'm just
living everyday life oh this is this is
the truth and that's the way it feels
it's been many many years I'm slowly
starting to have a different set of
feelings like oh this is a headset I'm
now rendering that chair I'm now
rendering that light it's but it's very
very slow for it mean usually I fall
back into the normal I'm just immersed
in the truth but virtual reality is
actually helpful to actually spend time
in a virtual reality world which you
realize oh yeah I'm rendering a full 3d
world now I just deleted that whole 3d
world I'm not rendering it anymore oh
wow that's maybe what's also happening
in everyday life the headset when I take
off a virtual reality headset there's
another headset that I've always had on
that I didn't know and it's what I
called reality but it's just another
virtual world that evolution programmed
into us and so but I would say I would
say I'm maybe 98% in I'm this is the
truth and 2% of the time now so as you
know after years it so it doesn't go
away easily and does that affect the way
you interact with other people does it
kind of um is it challenged the way you
see you you communicate with people what
does it mean for our relationships to
think that actually what we see is and
what there is is it harder to trust
another person if you think that this is
all a mirage and it's just an icon on my
desktop well I think that it gives me a
deeper respect for how much more
complicated people are than what we can
literally see where you know the the
example I gave of your seeing your face
in the mirror and realizing that the the
range of a inferences I can make about
what you're feeling and thinking based
on your expressions in your body
language is really a small fraction of
of who you really are and all the the
richness mean so I can just see small
nuances of a smile but there are many
many nuances of feeling happy and bliss
that are completely lost on me that I
know exists personally but I don't know
which one you're having and so one thing
I think it does is it makes me really
appreciate that
I shouldn't assume I know what you're
really feeling I should really be
careful to engage more and to to you
talk more so it gives you that kind of
perspective evolutionary psychology also
that will some work by in cognitive
neuroscience and evolutionary psychology
also makes me be very very careful we
know that in there's certain split brain
patients they've had epilepsy and that
wasn't curable by the available drugs
and so they did a surgery where they cut
the brain in half so that the right
hemisphere was separated from the left
hemisphere and if the right hemisphere
went into an epileptic seizure maybe the
left wouldn't go into it and it worked
clinically if it was very very helpful
but what we found was we literally cut
consciousness in half with a knife
the right hemisphere ends up having you
can show in experiments you can give it
a completely separate content of
consciousness it can be aware of for
example the word key whereas the left
hemisphere is aware of the word ring and
nobody is aware of the phrase key ring
or the two together and we find that the
personalities are different the right
hemisphere often has a different
personality than the left and that the
left the one person for example that vs
Roma Condren studied the left hemisphere
believed in God the right hemisphere was
an atheist very very big difference in
personalities and the left hemisphere as
it turns out likes to make up stories
it's a confabulate er or a Steve Pinker
puts it a baloney generator and the
right hemisphere and many people tends
to be a little bit more in tune with
reality and also a little bit less happy
so so that that kind of knowledge also
affects my social relations it affects
my relationship with myself I don't
believe most of what I used to think
were my true motivations for why I'm
behaving the way I do much of that is
probably just baloney that I'm making up
to make myself seem rational and
reasonable and a good nice guy but then
most everybody else is doing the same
thing we're really hiding our true
motives and so that's why it's
difficult and personal relationships not
like we're consciously being
disingenuous it's an automatic
self-promotion mechanism that's built
into us and so these kinds of insights
that we get from the science not just
from my theory but from cognitive
neuroscience and you know split brain
operations and so forth really do begin
to affect how I understand people but
but not to say that I end up with a
negative view of people I think it's
it's just healthier to understand in
great greater depth the complexity of
people I think that it I shouldn't take
as much for granted as I used to and
shouldn't make as many assumptions about
people and why they're behaving as they
used to so people now seem even more
real to you that's right I'm proposing
that your consciousness is a fundamental
reality in this vast social network of
conscious agents and what one thing that
comes out and what the math is in my
theory is that when two conscious agents
interact they create a new single
conscious agent and this so you can have
very very simple agents that have very
very simple like only two experiences
and maybe two actions that they can take
I call them one bit agents but when two
of these one bit agents interact you get
a two bit agent that has maybe four
possibilities and and by the time you
get to me I don't know how many billions
or trillions or who knows how many but
then think about my two hemispheres
there's evidence that when the corpus
callosum is cut they have separate
consciousnesses with potentially
separate contents and separate
personalities and even separate
religious beliefs but when they're
connected with the corpus callosum
there's what I call me there seems to be
a single unified person and so that's
not another interesting thing that comes
out of this is trying to understand this
theory opens up the idea that that
you're real and that you're also too
conscious agents not just one conscious
agent you're two and the theory says
you're a whole infinite lattice all the
way down to these simple 1-bit agents
going all the way up to the two
hemispheres and finally to the one agent
that's you
then the theory leaves open the
possibility that that just in
interacting with other conscious agents
other agents are being formed and but
apparently I mean I don't experience
that and it's an interesting thing to
look at in the mathematical theory how
much can an agent know about the agents
that are emerging from its experiences
or interactions with other agents there
is some peer achill data on this Michael
Gazzaniga working with these split-brain
patients asked nor talked with a guy
with several of them they have this
blueprint operation me ask the person
does it feel any different now with the
split brain operation than it did before
and one one video I've seen the person
said absolutely not it feels just the
same as it was before and what we know
is that that's the left hemisphere
talking only of the left hemisphere can
talk
the right hemisphere can't talk to quit
it understands language and we know the
left hemisphere is a conveyor so when I
saw that I was going ok well maybe the
left left hemisphere was just saying you
know nothing to see here because trying
to make everything papered over but the
right hemisphere typically is not as
much as a [ __ ] fabulous so I asked
Gazzaniga a few weeks ago what about the
right hemisphere when you asked the
right hemisphere does it also say that
there's no difference and he said read
my book and he pointed me to he gave me
actually offered me his PDF he's so very
very kindly I looked in his book and the
answer is yes the right hemisphere also
says that it doesn't notice the
difference that's stunning data that's
some of the most important data that
I've ever seen from the split brain
stuff it's saying that the two
hemispheres there are 43 billion neurons
in the cortex of the right - here - 43
billion in the left and the right
hemisphere saying when I got cut off
from those 43 billion other neurons I
don't notice a difference that is a
stunning bit of data - can you know
to use in trying to frame a theory of
consciousness when to consciousness is
interact how do you create a new
consciousness and how much do the
lower-level consciousness actually know
about the higher-level consciousness
maybe almost nothing maybe nothing in
which case that's a stunning so you can
see there the possibility is that this
whole framework opens up when we take
consciousness is fundamental I start
looking at the neuroscience data in this
new way it's giving us insights into how
we might want to constrain our theories
of how consciousness works and what
happens when consciousness is interact
it's a completely new way of thinking so
does this mean that the two parts of our
brain interact a lot more than we think
what does it mean that they are both
quite autonomous and they they rapidly
they mirror each other or we're just
talking here you know I have a feeling
I'm just one person I don't have the
feeling of like to really separate
individuals that are negotiating and and
one is an atheist and one's a believer
and one's happy I mean sometimes you
might feel a little struggle do I do I
want a party tonight or do I want to
study I mean they're a little and maybe
you get little hints of some kind of but
most of time we feel like we're just a
single unified thing and yet we have
clear evidence that there's two so so I
don't know what to say it seems like it
it you know we're both that we're that
you are one but that the one that's
talking to you right now is not aware of
the two separate consciousness is and
those are probably not aware of the the
consciousness is underneath them when I
teach a psychology class I teach
introduction to psychology for freshmen
at the University I'll tell them at some
point during the course that 99% of all
mental processes are unconscious the way
that's normally interpreted is to say
that the brain is real most brain
processes don't give rise to
consciousness the ones that give rise to
consciousness are really just a tiny
fraction less than 1% I'm I'm turning it
around the other way
I'm saying it's consciousness all the
way down this is this whole vast social
network of conscious agents but my
interface has to simplify things so I
only can see my my whole network in
terms of what I call my body high levels
I've view it in terms of what I call my
psychology in my modes further on down I
call it my neuroscience my chemistry my
biology my physics but those are all my
interface just getting more and more
giving up at trying to represent what's
going on in this vast social network so
all I can do is see myself through my
interface description and what I see is
a body which is hiding this vast network
of conscious agents which is all
coordinating together to create the
single consciousness that's talking to
you so that's you can see it's a
completely different picture of what it
is means to be a human being and it
gives a new sense to what it means to be
embodied I mean embodied cognition is I
think important but this gives a new
sense that even our embodiment itself is
a picture that we come up with thank you
very much for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you